space isn't bad and if it wasn't for
like the personality and the the job and
the you going out to your mom with to
the bars he could be you know like a
five or six I feel like he has a face
that's not like ugly do you know what
I'm saying like his face is like like
it's ugly because he's fat like if he
wasn't fat he'd probably just be I think
most people would be normal looking if
they weren't fat I think there's very
few people that like their face is so
bad that it's like you know what I mean
there's some I just yeah maybe he'd be a
four I don't know but my point is we
need to get some uglier broads at these
parties you don't qualify for these
women